everyone to a party and a bunch of
people are joking and then you're like
you walk into the circle and they sell
some inside joke and they're like you
had to be there and you're like okay you
want the opposite of that with your
content so if you're always making
content specifically for your audience
as in it references past content that a
new person wouldn't know about without
explaining what it means or giving the
context they're going to feel like the
odd man out what you want to do in my
opinion is make all your content for
someone who's brand new and people who
already consuming your stuff are okay
with the few you know the hey by the way
if you're new to this channel XYZ that's
okay they're not going to stop watching
you as long as you're still providing
value but for the new person who's
walking in it can make all the
difference in the world the reason you
do this is it grows your audience faster
if you make them feel included